zombies you know I love them and if you
do to dying lights got them and not just
your typical slow-moving stupid zombies
like this idiot right here no dying
light features over 10 unique zombies
that live to make your day in her on a
dead one without do here's a rundown on
the zombies you'll encounter and how to
take them down without the use of
firearms warning this video may contain
spoilers before we get rolling there are
three items I highly recommend you
should always carry one throwing stars
preferably exploding two firecrackers
three and probably the most powerful
item in the game multiple cocktails also
the Dropkick agility skill because it's
helpful in very addicting your standard
run-of-the-mill stupid good for nothing
but heads one-on-one no prob just be
wary of biter groups how to kill them
well I'll leave that up to you my
preferences include fire bowling and my
personal fave the dropkick impalement
you can alert and group them with some
firecrackers then hit them with that
dropkick bam
looks good you got two types of goons
you got the medium build ones who can
wield weapons and then you got the more
jacked up goons like this guy these
meatheads lug around rebar mallets it's
okay take a deep breath check your
surroundings do you see any propane or
gas tanks okay good you're gonna want to
do is lure them towards one don't stay
put get them close enough and then GTF
Oh sometimes these goons like to play
fireman making them fireproof in which
case I recommend the old one - that's a
dropkick to stun and then throw in two
hits no more or he'll push you down
resulting in your demise the good news
because these guys wear masks they don't
fight you the bad news their protective
suits make them fireproof more good news
they wear gas takes that once punctured
explode in seconds more bad news
sometimes their punctured tanks propel
them in random directions like say
wherever you are
pull this off once and it's all you'll
want to do guess what that explosion you
this cause yeah I just alerted these
freaks and as the game progresses you'll
see more and more of them sure you can
take them on give them the old drop kick
but when you got three or more on you
you're better off outrunning them in a
parkour match these sick bastards hock
up poison loogies and spit from the far
think of them as the zombie sniper or
Archer or I bet see one of these dudes
in the lot take them out first here's
where your malt off or throwing stars
come in handy
scratch that
totes come second two bombers you can
spot these guys coming a mile away based
solely on their I have something up my
butt run which makes perfect sense
because they actually have inflated
organs which makes them so bloated they
explode and their constipation with a
throwing star yes they are really big
but don't let that intimidate you while
their size and power may be high they
are extremely dumb throwing propane
tanks and cocktails does the trick fine
and apparently goal posts oh what a big
dumb idiot
oh these small sticky zombie children
are total brats and need be taken down a
peg or two their ear piercing screams
don't just stun you they attract other
zombies so put these babies down by
snapping their necks once you've put the
kids to sleep it's time to hit the town
because that's where the party's really
act zombies absolutely love to party at
night goons get all jacked up and turned
into virals but that's the least of your
worries
bullet tiles are the worst and avoid
them at all costs don't even bother
trying to take them down
just run switch to UV flares and UV
flashlights to slow them down and if you
still can't lose them make your way to
the nearest UV covered safe house
vultures like to party at night too but
think of them as the volatiles weird shy
younger brother that only drinks milk
groups of volatiles will protect
Boulter's but managed to lure them away
and you can easily take one out with a
ninja star take a bolter skin and you're
able to craft bolter poison which will
allow you to create and
I quote the most toxic poison weapon in
the history of her on so that's cool and
there it is
your guide to killing zombies in dying
light I hope you learn something today
and if you got any sweet moves or
tactics put them in the comment section
that's it for me see you later